uh look and and
and let me begin with this disclaimer
because
after the show's over and during the
show i'll get emails from people who say
almost literally in alternating fashion
quit talking about the pandemic
keep talking about the pandemic
you don't know what you're talking about
thank you for talking sense into
everyone right
the reality is folks
we don't show up at the production
meeting and say well first of all let me
just say we don't show up at the
production meeting period
we don't go into these shows
with
any
agenda other than to talk about what's
going on in the nfl
and our producers do an excellent job of
ensuring that we at least stay in the
general vicinity
of the things that are
you know
going on in the nfl
so when we talk about the pandemic it's
not because chris or me or both of us
have said we must talk about the
pandemic today no
it's because there's something that's
going on
with the intersection of covet 19 in the
nfl that forces us to do so so chris
i don't know that that's going to reduce
the number of emails
that i get telling me don't talk about
the pandemic today
but
well at least i hope we're all on the
same page as we move forward well yeah
we're we're talking about the news and
what's relevant in the nfl like you have
said this is the biggest story in the
nfl right now i mean we might have a
team that doesn't play games for two
weeks in a row so you're i think we're
totally justified in doing that because
it is the biggest story going around and
it might affect the whole season and
we're going to see where that goes
you know anyways here and to the
emailers out there who complain about
the cove and talk listen
i'm exhausted about talking to coven
about covet 19. when i saw two more
positive tests on the titans yesterday i
went oh
oh no
we're gonna have to open the show
tomorrow to talk about this even more so
it's not like you and i are raising our
hand like you're saying going hey we
need to do another segment in covid we
need we more coveted please more covered
please
no it's just the facts of the matter is
that's where it's leading us right now
in the sport that's the big story and
we're concerned that we're going to have
games missed or maybe a delay in the
season or whatever else and that's why
we're talking about it
yeah and what happened yesterday and a
lot of this stuff happens while we're on
the air and i fully expect at some point
between now and 9 a.m eastern time we
will find out whether there are any more
positives in new england any more
positives in tennessee any more
positives in las vegas where maurice
hurst had a positive result earlier this
week and they have to worry about this
chain reaction driven by the incubation
period driven by the flaw in the system
that comes from getting the nasal swab
in the morning and getting the result of
the off-site pcr test at some point
well after the fact they still haven't
perfected the technology where they can
get a good reliable outcome
at a time when you can say to someone
you better not go in the building today
you're positive yeah see that's what i
always thought they would have basically
an airlock right where you walk in you
get your nose swapped you get your mouth
swab you get a finger prick whatever it
is i thought they'd be able to do that
and know then and there is the person
positive but no you get the test you go
to work you find out later if you're
positive meanwhile you're in the
building all day that that's a flaw in
the process another flaw in the process
that i hadn't even really crystallized
in my own brain they don't test these
guys at all on game days on sundays they
don't test them at all no pcr test no
point of care test
so your last test is saturday right on
monday they do drive through testing
because nobody goes to the building
except people getting treatment
well the people who get treatment still
end up in the building
and the last time anybody was tested was
saturday
given the way the numbers are going up
nationally that's just not acceptable so
we're going to have positives and that's
the that's where the league is on this
chris i've talked to some people
yesterday and there are some coaches who
are just pissed off about the way this
is all being handled because they
believe the league's attitude is
if you follow our protocols you'll be
fine
therefore if you're not fine
you didn't follow our protocols yeah so
it's on you right our protocols are fine
our pro our protocols are better than a
bubble
that was a comment made by dr alan sills
yeah on monday
the topic of a bubble came up well no no
no our protocols are better than bubble
if you follow our protocols you'll be
fine see they accept the fact people are
going to go home and they're going to
get it
they're going to bring it in but if you
follow our protocols
it's not going to spread
and and
it's just not realistic
the locker room in kansas city the
visiting team locker room hey a thousand
square feet thousand square feet you've
been there thousand square feet yeah no
it's ridiculous and that's where the
patriots were monday night yeah right
they asked for more space and they were
told no i mean it's one of those locker
rooms where you can't get dressed to the
next to the guy next to you it's that
tight it's worse than my high school
locker room i mean and i didn't have
like a great high school locker room
either so for people to make jokes yeah
it is not you know conducive for the
environment we're in right now where
we're trying to social distance and do
that wouldn't be possible in that locker
room i mean it is literally one of those
things where you go oh wait this guy's
getting changed in his uniform i better
walk over here or i'm going to have him
like you know his butt in my face the
whole time i mean i'm sorry but that's
how tight it is in there i mean it
really is i mean you know of course len
dawson was in there smoking cigarettes
900 years ago i don't
know that was in miami that was miami i
know yeah um but but uh yeah you know
you you opened the door there for
speculation that your dad pulled the
phil knight and wrote a big check for a
really swanky high school locker yeah
realize what
high school or something like that it
was a nice high school but we weren't
like yeah you know lavish facilities or
anything like that no but that's a
problem that's not the only stadium
where the visiting team locker room
isn't very big so that that
that necessarily
makes it impossible to comply with the
protocols you must stay six feet apart
at all times well if you're gonna wedge
us into this sardine can we can't do
that as we're getting ready for a game
or as we're getting ready to leave after
a game and we're sweating and we're
breathing and there's there's just it's
just it's the
it's the petri dish that is any locker
room so there's a lot of stuff that's
just kind of conveniently being
overlooked as the nfl tries to legislate
from on high what all the teams must do
without recognizing the protocols may
not be as perfect as believe now with
the titans
there were two more positive players
yesterday it turned out one of them was
inconclusive well that person's getting
tested again got tested again yesterday
we'll find out what the results were at
some point while we're on the air
presumably they've now had 20 people
in all over the past two weeks who have
tested positives and to make matters
work setting aside
how and why
the virus spread and i'm told that the
league office is telling teams that
they've got video in the titans facility
if guys just walking around like it's
2019. yeah like no masks like nothing's
going on that's not good and the titans
are going to face a consequence for that
if it's true chris
that
they had off-site tom brady style
practices
last week when they were told not to
that's even worse and there are the
photos if you're watching on tv or
peacock
that's even worse and there's there's
chatter there's a buzz there's a
murmuring in league circles the titans
are going to get hit in a way that no
team has ever been penalized for
violating the rules worse than the
patriots have ever been penalized yeah
that's what's coming for the titans it's
just a matter of time well i i mean i
understand it i mean i do i mean because
you know in a year like this if you're
doing things like that egregiously wrong
or not listening or anything like that
to what the rules are in the in the
current nfl and where we are
you can ruin the season for everybody
yeah i mean we could talk about other
teams who have gotten fined and whatever
else and yeah they did things ooh you
know that you know whatever you have
your discrepancies there but none of it
ever went into they're ruining the
season for everybody all 31 other teams
in the league so yeah we're we're in
unprecedented waters here there and you
know again to to there's there's a lot
of things i want to say here you know
first off yeah the nfl protocol system
is really good is it perfect no you're
exactly right
but
i mean as we know the coaches and the
players and i've we've we've said from
the start and i know i've said from the
start right that they they don't care
about covet so if they're not being
watched over at all times they're not
going to follow protocols they're not
they care about covid because they don't
want people they care about or have to
be responsible for somebody else getting
it and then something bad happened and
they respect it that way but just people
in the nfl if nobody's looking and
they're around each other yeah they're
gonna walk around the facility with no
mascot they're gonna do whatever i mean
not everybody but that's the way it's
gonna go
and then
mike with the
the the like i i feel for the players in
like
the ones that may have gathered there at
mba montgomery montgomery bell academy i
used to live right there when i played
for the tennessee titans i used to go
work out there and throw footballs
before training camp started and did
everything
it
what do you do as a player you know
that's where it's really tough like yeah
you want to follow the rules but damn we
might have to play a game on sunday and
nobody's going to care in a few weeks
like i'm not going to get the excuse of
hey that guy didn't get to practice or
throw a football week until sunday
that's going to get lost you know it's
going to get washed away so as an
athlete and a competitor as a player
you're thinking wait i'm going to be
judged on this performance no matter
what nobody's going to care about the
circumstances that we're dealing with
and i want to try to be at my best and
i'm competitive and want to win and beat
that other damn team and that's where i
feel for the player they're stuck in an
un
you know a non-tenable yeah exactly just
a no winning position you can't win in
the position they're in and then that's
where i go back to again the mike florio
special where i go it's another reason
we need 32 bubbles it's the reason we
need every team bubble because you can't
trust the players you can't really trust
the coaches the protocols are really
good but they're not perfect and
i think it's just going to be the only
way that makes it all happen
you also can't trust the players to be
discreet which makes it easier for the
nfl to prove that there was a violation
right to the extent that anyone out
there would say well you can't prove
that that's titan players in those
photographs you don't need to roger
saffold apparently never hearing the
advice from jimmy conway never read on
your friends and always keep your mouth
shut he flat out said guys don't work
out for fun they don't work out for fun
this is for their livelihood not the
exact spelling of the term but we get
the point yeah okay why don't you just
go ahead and admit it you did it you did
it and now you're gonna get whacked
you're gonna get whacked in a way that
no team has ever been whacked now it's
not like i don't yeah look i don't know
what they're gonna do to the players
here but the organization is gonna get
this one it's gonna be money it's gonna
be draft pick or two or more it's gonna
be
maybe
individual punishment for the people who
are in charge of the team you know at
first i was on board with this idea that
there's a little witch-hunt quality to
the league going around to the teams
anytime there's an outbreak saying let's
find out how we can blame you right not
our protocols and the protocols do have
flaws even though the league wouldn't
admit it
in this case
i i've i've now
decided to not extend the benefit of the
doubt to the titans i decided not to try
to find a way to make this look like a
witch hunt we found the witch right we
sometimes you find a witch and the witch
is the players disregarding the
instruction to not get together and work
out while they're trying to get their
arms around whether to what extent
there's been an outbreak because look we
don't know now whether that drip drip
daily stream of positives
was a result of the outbreak that
happened before they went to minnesota
and played the vikings or
as a result of them ignoring
the instruction to go home and stay home
so they can properly monitor
the consequences of this outbreak yeah
that's completely screwed up that case
study now by having those guys get
together away from the team facility
yeah you're right you know i never
really thought about that aspect uh
you're you're exactly right it increases
the chances of
if there was that one guy like you're
saying where okay it hasn't formulated
enough in the body yet to produce a
positive test but he's out there now
practicing with the guys yet did that
add on to
what we're seeing here i mean i don't
know but obviously there's issues in
tennessee there was issues before we
knew some of this stuff you know there
was a lot of rumors that there might
have been protocols broken and issues
there so we'll see where this goes but i
would think that the nfl is probably
pissed off uh and and probably realizes
there's a lot of issues with a lot of
teams but tennessee seems to be the most
egregious we've seen to this point
yeah absolutely and you mentioned the
bubble idea something that we've been
talking about something that needs to be
done the washington post reported on
wednesday no serious consideration at
this point
either for a
home market bubble where all teams would
be confined to individual hotels or
pressing pause on the season to regroup
that's something that a couple of
coaches suggested last week when these
issues first really started to boil the
idea of a 12 game season
where
you basically regroup for now reduce the
season regroup let's get it figured out
let's come up with a better plan if it's
a bubble it's a bubble although a lot of
coaches don't want to do that but the
idea of saying hang on
time out
let's just
pause everything and get this all
figured out the nfl does not want to
miss games the nfl does not want to
postpone games the nfl doesn't want
forfeits of games the nfl wants 256
games to be made available to the
networks so that the nfl gets every last
pen and i got no problem with that yeah
i got no problem
the idea of wanting
to
make sure your full inventory of product
right is made available to your customer
i've got no problem with that at all but
there is a point
where the
obsession with getting all the games
played
doesn't
mesh with
player health and safety coach health
and safety health and safety of everyone
else who's in that vicinity who goes to
that facility every single day knowing
that the league's protocols accept the
fact that somebody's going to show up
positive from time to time because
everybody goes home that concept we've
been talking about for a week now the
170 stories to be told in every
organization yeah where everyone goes
who they interact with who comes to
their house where the people in their
house have been that day there's 170
different stories for 32 different teams
you only avoid that by having a home
market bubble the nfl says no serious
consideration of it and i
i think
i don't know this yeah this is just
common sense after 20 years of following
this yeah every single day
i think the league does not want to have
to go to the union
and ask for this because the unions
already said no to a thursday to sunday
bubble that was during the negotiations
before the season even began
but
the union's not going to say okay you
know what we understand it we get it and
we don't want anything more from you to
do it we'll just decide this is a
win-win that's not how collective
bargaining works and that's how the nfl
has always approached collective
bargaining like the marijuana policy
it's made sense for years for the for
the league to dramatically soften if not
get rid of it but any time it came up
you know three four five years ago as
more and more states were beginning to
legalize it for medicinal and
recreational purposes what we would hear
from the commissioner was it's a matter
of collective bargaining which is code
for we're not giving up anything unless
you give us something back so the
union's going to use that on them if
they ask for a bubble which is why
they're not asking for a bubble because
they don't have to give the union
anything more than what they've already
given them so that's why they're not
doing it yeah not because it's the best
thing to do but because they don't want
to be over a barrel with the union when
the union says
what are you going to do for us if we
put all of our players in a hotel for
three months i mean at what point mike
do you think the union goes
i mean when is it danger mode to go okay
well for the betterment of our players
and for them to get paid and let's
protect them that way i mean you know
we're we're
we're like flirting with danger here
we're on the danger line right now i
mean at what point will the nflpa just
go you know what nfl you're right we
don't want anything back we want to make
the season work too i mean
that we're right around the corner from
that to where you're right you're
absolutely right that's where it bothers
me i mean i just i don't get that i mean
this is not the time to be playing like
johnny hardball at the negotiating table
i don't agree with that and i don't like
that and i i hope the nfl will just
breach the conversation or break the ice
and get it going
i think the nfl pa
at this point believes that no matter
what the nfl will find a way to get the
games played without forcing the players
into a hotel in their home market
and the idea of games being forfeited
games being postponed and not made up
teams
getting into the playoffs or not based
on 15 or 14 games that the union beli
and i don't know this i just think this
is why we're at this point where the
league is actually telling teams that
its current protocols is better than a
bubble you know we got to worry about
the housekeeping staff we got to worry
about the janitorial staff we have to
worry about well it worked for the nba
yeah that's right for the nhl exactly
and there's a way to do it to keep clear
of those folks they can clean your room
when you're at practice right you don't
have to hang out in the same room with
the the maintenance guy who needs to fix
your tv your tv can get fixed while
you're at practice or while you're
eating a meal
these are easily handled and it worked
for the nba and the nhl i think this is
just the union
believing that no matter what even if
they have to delay the end of the season
they have to reconfigure the schedule
they're going to get the games in so
we're not going to yield on this
until they give us something and
eventually the union may have to say
well you know what they weren't just
making an idle threat they really are
going to cancel games and we're going to
lose game change right and now we better
figure out what to do and maybe it needs
to come to that point before they go
into a bubble but maybe maybe there does
need to be
four five six seven eight lost games it
can't be rescheduled before the union
says okay fine we'll go into the bubble
for the rest of the season yeah i mean
uh un unfortunately it does seem that
way yeah it does it you know i don't
know it seems just to be
you know consistent with society
everything has to hit us in the face
until we realize well that's not right
um
but like
you know at some point too you know just
thinking about myself as a player and
putting myself in those shoes and i was
a player rep at one time for the tampa
bay buccaneers and all that
you know the nfl pa too with the delayed
season and all those things they got to
start worrying about player safety with
the players too it ain't good for the
players we're seeing already they've
dropped like flies it's not going to be
good for hey three weeks off hey come
back and get in a tough battle a week
off then take another tough battle and
have this season drawn out for whoever
knows how long when you can't really
train and do the things the right way
either to where you know that could be
a a really affect players long-term
health and what their careers are and
everything like that so at some point i
think the nfl pa has to be very
cognizant of that fact and go you know
what we just got to get this done now
and do what's best for right now and uh
and see where it goes because those are
the things i worry about yeah we're
playing football in march still
but you know yeah guys are all over the
place you're not going to get a real
feel for what teams are that way if
you're taking teams you know a week off
this team had two weeks off this team's
played two weeks in a row it'll be all
over the place and yeah we'll get to a
champion but it'll be about as a flawed
champion as we've ever seen if that's
the case where this this the seasons all
jumbled up and stretched out through a
number of weeks
and to your point regarding player
health and safety
one of the emails at least one of the
the themes of the emails that will come
in during and after the show is the idea
that well the mortality rate for players
is ridiculously low it's only going to
make ill and or kill people who are
older and who have comorbidities well
you've got some players who have
comorbidities you've got some players
with extremely high body mass indexes
you've got some players with some health
conditions that they either know about
or don't know about and see
all we ever hear chris
is that cam newton is asymptomatic this
player is asymptomatic but you know what
for all the players who have tested
positive we don't have a regular update
on how they're doing no you're right and
i'm comfortable saying this because of
the sheer number of positive cases in
tennessee
let's not assume that all those people
are asymptomatic in fact let's not
assume
that all those people are perfectly fine
let's not assume that at least one of
them is in bad shape right now this
isn't something that's going to be
broadcast because of privacy concerns
but
you get 20 people who have this
and you get within those 20 people folks
who are in risk groups
you really are playing russian roulette
yeah that's right it's not it's not
about ah these guys are healthy these
guys are fun you're just being a karen
go hide under the bed look you get that
many people
who are sick
or potentially sick that many people who
are infected there's gonna be some that
are asymptomatic there's gonna be some
that are mildly symptomatic there's
gonna be some that get sick and you may
have one that dies
and and that's
a concern as well
and and that's where some coaches are
very upset
the league harps on player health and
safety
but now the league has these protocols
that may not properly
respect the health and safety interests
of the players and
and of the coaches you know i'm starting
to hear that coaches are getting
concerned there was never really that
conversation about how and why and when
a coach could opt out of the season
right because the coaches don't have a
union
the coaches don't have a union so the
league told me early on this is a team
by team decision as to what options will
be available for coaches who aren't
comfortable coaching this year right
well
you know what some teams just don't have
one they just don't it never came up you
know because the coaches are trying to
project strength exactly and and vigor
and vitality
right so they're not going to go to the
head coach and say you know i'm having
concern no you're on the bus the bus is
moving yeah right let's go we got
football season coming the conversation
never happens now we're getting to a
point where there's outbreaks in two
different cities and cold and flu season
is here and the numbers are going up and
you got some coaches that are saying
i'm not sure this is the smartest thing
for me to do i don't know that i should
be coming to this petri dish every day
yeah where there's a potential outbreak
and and so that's another side of this
how much do we really care about the
health and safety of the individuals or
how much of it is frankly
the league wanting to be able to say we
didn't do anything wrong our protocols
are fine if you have a problem it's your
problem you're the one on the lawsuit
not us you're the one that's carrying
around this guilt not us our protocols
are fine if there's a problem if one of
your people gets sick 40 people dies
it's on you not us yeah i mean yeah i
don't like that approach of course
because it is us problem we know that i
mean as far as the nfl is concerned it's
yeah it's everybody oh hey somebody
somebody dies it's definitely an us
problem definitely you may be able to
say you can't sue us hey we have good
protocols our protocol here's here's a
here's a uh an army of expert witnesses
coming to testify under oath that our
protocols are fine yeah that's fine but
it's still an nfl problem right exactly
i think all the time chris what if corey
stringer had died now right right
stringer died in 2001 it was like
everybody just kept going right that's
not the way it would go now no if
somebody dies of covet 19 or anything no
and you know i think two of you know if
it got to that point too it'd be like oh
yeah your protocols are so good they're
they're so good that a guy like stefan
gilmore was on the field hugging players
and
uh you know who knows who he's in
contact with with on the patriots and
being involved in all that too so you
know that protocol like stands i don't
think how i don't see how that could you
know
you know stand the test of time in a
fight like that either um and then also
yeah chris yes they they made the rule
in july they made the rule in july that
after the games no jersey swaps and you
can't get within six feet of anyone else
from the other team right that was the
rule july the 8th i asked yesterday is
this still the rule because you know
what after every game
that we're seeing
these interactions
like they had a receiving line for tom
brady after the game against the charges
my guess is that's the case every week
he just stands there while they all come
up to kiss the ring of the pope yeah on
the other team yeah of course and we saw
stefan gilmore and patrick mahomes face
right but that's still the rule it has
not been enforced at all but that's
still the rule well you know six feet
together i think that's again the the
nfl however they want to do it i mean
obviously they're gonna have to be more
strict with everything with everything
because you can't trust the players and
you can't trust the coaches like like
you said you know we've talked about it
so the nfl it's gonna be on them to kind
of you know
self-scout the players or scout the
players themselves to realize what the
hell they're doing and let's be on them
all the time let's have somebody at the
game
like on the sidelines as the clock is
ticking down to go hey don't cross this
point or whatever it is hey hey this
team patriots you know don't cross the
hash hey chiefs don't cross your hash
say hello to each other good game guys
how you doing yeah blah blah blah see
you later but yeah there's there save
themselves from themselves and that goes
into the coaching thing as well because
you're right with the coaches you know
this is this is uh
de facto
you know army or
something like that that's the way the
nfl is coaches whether they're 75 or 62
or 28 oh the coach told us to come into
work today we got to go work i coach a
football team project strength do all
that even if they were concerned they're
not going to say it because that's just
not the way the nfl works that way so
yeah we talked about back at the time of
like coaches got to know their own staff
right to know who might be vulnerable or
who who is that but man that's that's a
lot of pressure to put on the coaches
too and a lot of these guys that they
might be worried about might just be
like no matter what just like hell you
know the hell with you no i'm fine i'm
coming no matter what i'm gonna be here
and yeah you worry about those guys
those older coaches that you know could
have some underlying health problems at
the ages they're at
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports